[Music]
this week on
forward look the entire rationale of Joe
Biden's run is that he was able to
reassemble the blue wall which was
destroyed by Trump in 2016 that in 2020
Joe Biden can put it together if we we
demonstrate how weak he really is uh in
this state and other states in the blue
wall the entire rationale for his
campaign evaporates I mean I'm not
looking to hurt the party we're trying
to help the party here we're trying to
save the party from itself at this point
exactly you know it's going to become a
sort of coastal Bourgeois party uh that
has no working class members in it and
that's that would be a really terrible
party to be in
[Music]
Frank it is my pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast senior advisor to the dean
Phillips campaign Bernie Sanders
campaign manager in 2016 and adviser in
2020 former head of our Revolution this
man has done a lot Jeff Weaver welcome
Jeff great hey thanks for having me
Andrew I appreciate it so Jeff you are a
longtime uh
political professional you were Bernie's
uh
OG independent gorial campaign manager I
believe you might have been his chief of
staff after he was in the house and then
the Senate how did you react when Bernie
came to you about him running for
president in 2016
yeah well that's a great story because I
had left his office in 2009 I had ran
ran his Senate campaign uh in 2006 I was
a senate chief of staff for a couple
years and I spent a number of years on
the house side as well as chief of staff
and I I was just want a little break
from politics so I left politics and
opened up my comic book business and uh
was having fun with that and then 2015
Bernie called me out of the blue he's
he's not one to call you much and uh
said Jeff would you like to have dinner
I was like something's up so I went and
had dinner with Bernie and uh he was he
was uh uh let's say taken aback by the
cost of everything the Washington
consultant class uh and he wanted
somebody who he knew was his guy in his
corner to make sure that his campaign
wasn't being looted he said to me he
saids you know everything costs $30,000
a month here in Washington you know this
one that one this consultant that
consultant so anyway that's how it
happened well that was a rousing
campaign I thought you guys should have
won
honestly with you on that I'm with you
on that yeah and um I dare say if Bernie
had been the nominee in 2016 I think
Bernie beats Trump I think there there
is no Trump um
one that's right and then here we are
about to see Trump too and history is
almost repeating itself where you're
like you know who's gonna beat Trump
Dean Phillips you know who's not GNA
beat Trump Joe Biden which by the way
that that's my feeling on all of this so
how did you react when Dean Phillips
called you uh much more recently yeah
well I you know like like you uh I've
had some serious doubts about whether
the president could beat Donald Trump uh
and but you know there was nobody out
there running as you well know and as we
know now Dean Phillips tried to get a
bunch of other people to run before
ultimately throwing his own hat uh into
the ring to provide folks an alternative
but uh you know was interesting
conversation he's obviously positioned
himself aesthetically as a as a Centrist
if you look at his voting record has a
solid Democratic voting record voted for
the entire agenda the first two years of
the administration um you know we talked
about Medicare for all which he you know
told me that he had been looking to to
to to adopt uh we talked about free
tuition at public colleges universities
you we talked about a number of uh
issues that are important uh to advance
and you know there was there was nobody
else willing to carry the banner this
time and uh you know uh getting to know
Dean Phillips incredibly charismatic guy
you know at heart a really very decent
person a nice person uh which is a
little bit rare in politics as we all
know he is a very nice person I agree
maybe too nice for this game well one of
the things I say is like you don't think
he's going to be it because he's so
congenial but he has the potential to be
the most transformative political figure
in quite some time yeah because he's
going to try and break the shackles of
the uh the duopoly well I I mean you can
imagine if uh you know this a former
businessman who's positioned himself as
a cous ultimately becomes the one to
bring Medicare for all to the country
would be a little ironic but uh but you
know
this is what happens you know for those
of us who've been in the Progressive
fields toiling for years and years you
know the issues that you know Bernie
talked about and others have talked
about have become more mainstream and it
is only logical that as those issues
become mainstream a broader and broader
range of political leaders will talk
about those issues and Champion those
issues and that's that's what victory
means you know when you have an issue
agenda as opposed to a a cult of
personality that's what that's what it
means you know that's what Bernie was
about was trying to advance a series of
an issue set to move the country forward
yeah I can relate to that um I I so so
Dean does say that he thinks there's a
very compelling Centrist in business
case for universal healthcare which I
totally agree with by the way I mean
it's breaking the backs of small
businesses it's increasing the cost of
everything because you just have these
climbing and climbing insurance premiums
and then you pass them on to customers
in various ways it locks up the
workforce because a lot of people feel
like they can't leave or else they going
to lose their insurance so that there
all of these problems uh that arise from
our current health care system so
there's a very compelling business case
for it okay so you sit down with Dean
you say wow this a nice guy wow he's
actually going to Champion some things
that uh I feel very very strongly about
but you're a professional and so you say
okay how the heck is this guy going to
win and uh this conversation is going to
be released to the public on February
5th um so South Carolina will have voted
uh both of us would be stunned if that
was somehow some like crazy Dean
very stunned Dean showing um but we'll
re-record if that happens yeah yeah sure
I'd be very happy to be my pleasure um
but both of us think that the major
opportunity is in Michigan in febru on
February 27th and we think it's kind of
a huge opportunity yes no it is
definitely a huge opportunity and uh
people will remember that Bernie won
Michigan in
2006 you mean 2016 uh 16 I mean 2016
sorry
I got I lost 10 years there somewhere uh
in 2016 in a surprise upset you know
Michigan is
a sort of microcosm of America you know
uh everybody thinks about it as just
bluecollar uh Auto industry which it is
obviously uh and they think of Detroit
um you know is a it's really the only
city there uh uh interestingly uh there
are more African-Americans in Michigan
than there are in South Carolina even
though we think of South Carolina as the
African-American um primary uh but there
are also small cities there are rural
areas uh and in 2016 you know Bernie
traveled all of them and I think Dean
will do the same thing uh Folks up there
really respond to the kind of they
haven't had a lot of retail politics so
if you are somebody who can practice
retail politics well as Dean Ken as we
saw in New Hampshire uh I think he's
going to do really well there he's gonna
he's gonna spark a lot of interest with
folks it is an Open Primary uh any they
don't have party registration in
Michigan so literally anybody who's
registered to vote can come out and vote
for
which creates a much bigger pool of
Voters you know New Hampshire uh
typically has a lot of independent
voters which it did this time but they
all flocked into the Republican primary
to vote for Nikki Haley there was a very
well-funded effort on the part of Nikki
Haley to get those Independents into the
Republican primary so you know it
disadvantaged Dean in uh uh New
Hampshire uh but in Michigan I think
you're going to see a lot of
Independence and perhaps even some you
know former Christie voters or folks
like that who might uh come over and
vote for Dean in the Democratic
primary hey all' if you know me you know
I'm not that handy in the kitchen and I
have become a huge believer and booster
of factor factor is delicious ready to
eat meals make eating a joy it's so fast
you just Pop That Thing 2 minutes later
and you are eating a restaurant quality
healthy meal making you feel excellent
about about yourself my favorite is the
turkey chili with zucchini and there is
so much more to choose from you never
get tired of it it fits any budget it's
fast healthy it is going to be the new
factor in your life yes I'm a fan head
to factor meals.com
sl50 and use code y50 to get 50% off
your first box and two free wellness
shots per box while subscription is
active that's code Yang 50
at factor meals.com
y50 to get 50% off your first box get
Factor today it's going to change the
way you
[Music]
eat yeah so by the Numbers the New
Hampshire Republican primary Drew
315,000 voters and the Democratic
primary such as it was Drew 110,000 so
if you can imagine let's call it 100,000
of the
Independence uh voting in the dean
versus Biden primary I bet Dean would
have gotten most of those votes and then
you can see him getting uh 40 45 even
winning that thing um but if you were in
New Hampshire as we were all you got
bombarded by was Nikki Hanley versus
Trump ads and so you'd think well that's
where the action is and so that's where
all the Independents voted now in
Michigan February 27 the odds are very
very high that Dean versus Biden is the
only game in town yes um because the
Republican South Carolina primary is on
February 24th and Nikki Haley will
almost assuredly lose very significantly
and it's going to be tough for her to
lose her home state by whatever the
number is 18 points and then say on
where let's go Michigan yeah yeah yeah
so there's a chance that she drops off
out before Feb 24 there's a very high
chance that she drops out on February 24
and then Dean might have the field all
to himself in the primary against Joe
Biden in a state that Joe Biden is
struggling in a poll came out recently
that had Joe Biden losing to Trump by
eight points in the general by the way
this is a state he won in 2020 so that's
that's a big sign and then if you
replaced Joe Biden with Gretchen Whitmer
the governor of Michigan all of a sudden
Whitmer beats Trump by four so that's a
12-point swing uh I agree with you that
Dean is a very good fit for the state
being from Minnesota I I said he plays
hockey and he's going to feel familiar I
mean Minnesota doesn't quite touch
Michigan it's a couple States over
so he's going to feel familiar he'll do
well in the upper peninsula if he gets
to the Upper Peninsula he'll do well um
I've spent a lot of time in Michigan I
don't know if you know that Jeff sounds
like you have two campaigning at Bernie
yes um but uh I I started an
organization that held its uh training
camp in Detroit um and i' I've been not
just to Detroit but around the state um
it's good fun uh I'll be there
campaigning um within for Dean um um in
February so that that's going to be a
blast and Joe Biden's particularly
vulnerable and this is going to be an
interesting bridge building exercise for
Dean but the Arab American Community has
completely turned their back on Joe
Biden in Michigan uh it's a
traditionally Democratic constituency
and they they're essentially saying look
none of us is gonna vote for Joe um some
of them are flirting with Cornell West
but some of them want to find a more
productive way to channel their energies
and if Dean can make that case to that
population that would be an enormous
inroad no it absolutely would and you
know Bernie did that in 2016 Arab
American community in uh uh Michigan was
critical to his victory there and it was
one of the few communities where we had
the support of the local uh business
Community the local religious leaders
the local journalism folks uh it was
sort of like what Hillary had everywhere
else uh and I you know I think Dean has
the potential to build that kind of
Coalition uh in Michigan you're right
that the the community is very very
upset with Joe Biden and the way he's
handled the War uh and uh you know Joe
Biden has already canceled some visits
there uh because there was fear that you
know he would be either poorly received
or no one would show up at all so
there's a good opportunity to make
inroads there I mean and you're right
about the importance of this look the
entire rationale of Joe Biden's run is
that he was able to reassemble the blue
wall which was destroyed by Trump in
2016 that 2020 Joe Biden can put it
together now you and I have seen these
polls in these Battleground States it's
not just Michigan obviously you
Wisconsin uh and others and you know
Pennsylvania if if Joe Biden if we we
demonstrate how weak he really is uh in
this state and other states in the blue
wall the entire rationale for his
campaign evaporates you know then it is
as he himself has says there are 50
Democrats who could beat Donald Trump uh
and probably there are 50 Democrats who
can do that but you know Dean Phillips
is the only one who has had the guts to
actually step up and try to do
it hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you yeah on the list of Democrats who
can defeat Donald Trump in my opinion
Joe Biden's not on the list you know
like there are 50 and then Joe Biden is
somewhere you know unfortunately below
that level um which is unfortunate but
that that's where we are yeah I I don't
say that to insult the president I mean
it's not a question of insulting the
president because I think by many
metrics his administration has been very
successful but if you just look you know
what polls are is you're asking voters
what they think so when voters are
telling you uh that they want someone
else and that's obviously true on the
Republican side they want somebody else
besides Trump too uh you you should
listen and you know we've heard from uh
the administration from the White House
you know two years ago these polls were
bad uh and they said well it's two years
out give it time you know it's a long
time in politics then it was 18 months
keep keep we we're going to get it then
it was year you know now we're nine
months eight months out and the and the
polls are worse the favorables are worse
y uh and so it's not getting better and
no one has been able to point out uh
what is going to be the magic moment
when suddenly all of this reverses
itself uh it's wild man I talked to
traditional Democrats and they feel like
ostriches with their heads in the sand
and and I say to them look if I were
just to show you two candidates and just
get rid of the names
like which candidate do you think is is
going a win and lose it's just they
can't accept a loss to Trump um tribally
and so if I say Hey Joe Biden's losing
Michigan by eight Joe Biden's losing
Georgia by eight both states he won he's
losing North Carolina by nine and that
was a state that he only lost by one
last time he's a 38% approval rating
he's 81 years old uh you know like you
just put any of the the the polls up
there and you say this is like a really
really
terrible approach uh and they spent $25
million in Michigan and other states
trying to butress Joe's numbers um
because they sensed he was slipping and
it had no effect they they beat everyone
over the head with a bomic message the 2
to 25 million by the way a very very uh
aggressive desperate move you know
before the vote yeah um but that was a a
massive litmus test in my opinion that
the message isn't going to hit like
people this is not ad campaign fixable
this isn't tweak something um and I've
been a candidate you actually have been
a candidate which was interesting to me
looking at your history Jeff we prefer
not to talk about that go ahead but
you've been around a candidate an awful
lot and you know what a candidate has to
do a candidate has to project energy
travel convince people do at least a
little bit of retail politicking at a
minimum do fredley interviews and I can
sense right now that the Biden team is
very very nervous about him doing just
about anything under the sun which is a
terrible recipe heading into a contest
against Trump no and you know as we were
talking about earlier and I think this
is true just as a practical matter
wouldn't you want to see Joe Biden
debate in the primaries before he's
going to be forced to debate in the
general election you know Trump is going
to desperately want to debate him and I
don't know how you can go all the way to
November without agreeing to debate your
opponent in the other party I mean it's
it's will be impossible uh so we should
have an opportunity to see Joe Biden
debate you know you know for a couple
hours on television and then voters can
make their assessment you know the
president is up to it President's not up
to it that's but that's you know that's
something for the voters decide and
what's you know what's happened too
often in Democratic party is you know
that party insiders now are making all
the decisions and we've seen that with
you know Dean being kept off the ballots
in some of these states and the result
is is that you know they've lost a lot
of white working-class people and now
the polling is showing that uh uh
workingclass Latinos working-class
African-Americans are starting to move
out of the party and that's a very very
dangerous situation I mean I'm not
looking to hurt the party fact quite
quite the opposite TR to part of year
we're trying to save from itself at this
point yes exactly you know it's going to
become a sort of coastal Bourgeois party
uh that has no working class members in
it and
that's that would be a really terrible
party to be in
frankly this podcast is sponsored by
Express VP VPN using the internet
without expressvpn is a little like
walking your dog in public without a
leash most of the time it might work out
but then that one time your dog could
run away or get dognapped it's better to
take a little bit of care especially
when it's as simple as using expressvpn
when I log on to the internet I just
click on expressvpn and I get beamed on
through an encrypted Network through a
server someplace I have no idea where it
is but then no one else does either it's
great they can't track you they can't
buy and sell your data you know it's
secure and you can get content from
other parts of the world so you can be
kind of international and Cosmopolitan
if that sounds good to you right now you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
free at expressvpn.com
yangang that's
expressvpn.com
[Music]
slang
it's Michigan Feb 27 a number of things
have to break in Dean's Direction so
will he retail politic of course will he
be successful people like him yes I mean
he'll be excellent at that um he does
need some money behind him Michigan is a
big state a much bigger State than New
Hampshire so it the the money I'll make
a Shameless plug right here go to de24
Dean 24.com and and give us a 25 or $50
contribution if you like Andrew
uh if you like or hate Jeff Weaver
uh pleas please please uh uh you know
consider giving us a small contribution
to help the cause move forward totally
agree d24 uh it's a small price to pay
to potentially help preserve Western
Civilization uh so you have uh retail
politic can check he'll get local media
check uh we need to get some money in
the door so that he can advertise in
Earnest check there'll be some press
opportunities for sure and there's more
coming you know there was a real as you
know during the New Hampshire primary
there was a real blackout of Dean
Phillips and so many people are going to
be like who's Dean Phillips and you're
gonna say who's Dean Phillips because
you know he just he he was kept during
the New Hampshire primary he basically
kept off MSNBC and I say basically I
mean totally kept off fromsn MSNBC CNN
very very very little coverage you know
uh started getting a little coverage on
Fox after the you know about the time of
the primary but the national media has
largely ignored him uh meanwhile they're
giving all kinds of coverage to
Republican candidates ramaswami and
Christie and others all of who were
languishing in single digits while
ignoring Dean Phillipson so that's
that's turning around and I think F
folks are going to get to see Dean on
the national programs and I think
that'll help raise his profile as well
yes you know one thing I I think could
be a key ingredient of this and this
will happen if Dean puts up a big number
in Michigan there are several Statewide
candidates who are terrified of running
with Joe Biden at the top of the the
ticket they actually saying to folks yo
I don't think I can win if it's Joe
Biden up there we met legislators in New
Hampshire who felt that way yeah so if
you have statewide or federal candidates
in the Democratic party uh who are given
the license to raise their hands and say
hey guys uh let's go with Dean I think
they'll take that opportunity out of
self-preservation if Dean can put up a
big enough number in New in Michigan so
and in my opinion he does not need to
win Michigan um but he needs to put up a
big number um and the historical analog
is Eugene McCarthy putting up 42% in New
Hampshire um so everyone can you know
see that parallel where if Dean were to
get 42% in Michigan I think all bets are
off and uh it's it's it's it's
pandemonium it's a he he will he'll be
the ultimate political disruptor of this
cycle uh and really you know open up the
fields uh uh probably for other
candidates as well I mean it will become
a a full-fledged primary I think and
that would be good for the party and
Dean has said it good for the party and
I agree with him yeah so if that were to
happen I think a bunch of the Michigan
delegation would actually raise our
hands and be like hey I'm gonna endorse
Dean now because like Dean at the top of
the ticket means I have a chance where
is Joe Biden at the top of the ticket I
don't I mean it's pretty direct yeah
that way um so you touched on the media
blackout longtime fans of mine remember
the MSNBC blackout of my campaign uh
Ariana picari was a producer who left uh
a little bit after the campaign
and then said I was given a list of
candidates never to have on air and you
are on that list and So that obviously
pained me but it also explained a lot
it's like oh there actually is a fix in
um at MSNBC in particular uh they have
essentially zeroed out Deans campaign in
the same way uh CNN is a little bit more
up the- middle um that you know that
they they'll frankly acknowledge that
Dean exists um and some people are happy
to have him on and have a real conv with
him and I had that experience too by the
way like CNN actually um was leagues
better to me than MSNBC was um
unfortunately a lot of Democratic
primary voters really just use MSNBC as
their main source of info uh how did
MSNBC treat Bernie back in the day on
both campaigns well not well I mean look
I I I mean you know the exception proves
a rule I think Chris Hayes was very fair
with Bernie often and uh a couple of
others but you know by and large it was
a very hostile environment I mean the D
the MSNBC even back then has functioned
as as an arm of the DNC it's really a
communication arm of the DNC and so you
know I know the right says that about
MSNBC but it happens to be true I mean
sometimes a you know watch a sto watches
right twice a day and on this the the
right is correct so you know you can
expect a chilly reception if you are uh
not totally in lock step step with
whatever the establishment of the
democratic party wants and so that's why
you had problems there Andrew you
weren't in lock step with everybody oh
yeah I was just a guy um and to your
point Fox is actually much more eager to
have Deon in part because uh he's
running against Joe Biden you know right
right with I I went on Fox many times in
2016 you know the only thing you have to
be careful of is you know sometimes
their their questions are Laden with
assumptions that you reject and so you
have to be clear make sure you reject
them before you actually answer the
substance of the question because you
know they're often over the top as as
you know
[Music]
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
we sleep more than we do just about
anything else even if you're hardworking
you know what I mean why sleep on a
mattress that's made for lots of people
when you can sleep on a mattress that's
personalized to you just take the quiz
at Helix sleep and get a mattress sent
to you that has a 100 night trial yep
three months and a 10 to 15year warranty
my kids seek out the Helix mattress in
the house it's their favorite one and I
got to say it wasn't made for them it
was made for me don't want to take my
word for it Helix has been awarded the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine it's going to make you
healthier and more energetic do
something that's actually going to
improve your health Helix is offering
20% off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
yangang and use code Helix partner2 this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now yeah no it it's an unfortunate
Dynamic um Jeff because what happens I'm
just going to speak for myself so you
say hey I'd like to make the case to
Democrat voters then MSNBC blots you out
and then you're like all right and then
you know who will have you on Fox but
then Fox does have a particular approach
to things and lens and so it ends up
pushing you in a particular direction um
very naturally where uh you know because
you could express a few points but
they'll ask you about one point about
let's say Joe Biden and then you're like
well I actually happen to believe this
so sure I'll say Joe Biden you know is
is uh you know like the wrong candidate
and uh you know and despite the fact
that
I appreciate a lot of Joe Biden's
accomplishments um you know I just don't
think he's the right candidate for 24 by
his own words um but this this media
environment is part of the
disillusionment a lot of Americans feel
um and I feel like you've been bagging
your head against this wall for longer
than just about any of us yeah I mean
you know in Hampshire there's a there
was a sort of really a big example of
this there was a conference of college
students from around the country uh and
the candidates the Democratic candidates
you know minus Joe Biden because he was
boycotting New Hampshire you know went
and spoke to them and then when the
media wrote the story about it they
described it as a room of of seventh
graders which the you know the students
took great offense to because they were
college students from around the country
and it's just that kind of you know
minimizing and belittling of people you
know by the media not really getting the
facts right I mean you know on Election
Day in New Hampshire you'll remember
that uh CNN was interviewing voters at
the polls and they interviewed a Haley
voter a trp voter and then they F they
only could find one Democratic voter who
said this woman said she was loved Joe
Biden and thought Dean was annoying
turns out without identifying her that
this was the you know the head of the
pro Biden Super PAC in in New Hampshire
uh with no identification whatsoever by
CNN that that's who that was so uh you
know people see this uh and they should
interview me Jeff and be like random
random guy random random guy thinks Joe
Biden's annoying loves
so much for balance and you know that's
just like that's just what you call
color coverage you know that's just
talking to random voters on Election Day
it's not the substantive coverage but
even there you can see the incredible
bias built in I would blame that woman
who just should have identified herself
and be like look you don't want to talk
to me I'm the freaking treasurer of the
Biden writing campaign you know instead
like like pretending being like Oh I'm a
woman on the street like I I thought
that was a little bit off yeah well I'm
pumped to be
building the dean machine with you um I
think that we have a chance to change
the direction of American politics on
February 27th in Michigan anyone
listening to this if you have friends in
Michigan let them know hey uh Dean
Phillips is on the ballot to save us
from the Trump vers Biden rematch that
none of us wants that in our opinion
Trump will probably win uh so if you'd
like to have a better uh sense of who's
in in office go meet Dean Phillips in
Michigan he'll be coming to a town near
you tell your friends if you're not in
Michigan uh send Dean's campaign a
couple of bucks if you can spare them um
but it's all going to come down to what
happens on Feb 27 I think it's a golden
opportunity most people looking up are
like H New Hampshire 20% H South
Carolina it's going to be very very low
in all likelihood um but Michigan is
achievable Michigan is doable a lot of
discont
with the president a lot of desire for
an alternative Dean's a great fit if
Nikki Haley's out the independent show
up in force they're the resources to let
people know who Dean Phillips is and
what he wants to do for the country I
think Dean Phillips can put up a
shockingly high number in Michigan on
Feb 27 and then all bets are off
everything could change we have to make
it happen though and Jeff I'm grateful
to you for putting yourself back into
the ring to help Dean and Zach and the
team make it happen yeah well I'm
pleased I'm pleased to be here and uh
you know I was actually very proud of
what we did in New Hampshire we held the
president
under we held the president under 65% uh
there were about 10,000 votes for looks
like for ceasefire um which you know
took votes from us and Nikki Haley
taking all the independence so I you
know I'm I'm I feel very very good about
what happened in New Hampshire I think a
lot of people were actually surprised uh
by the performance you know South
Carolina was always going to be tough
the president's very popular there he
has longtime personal talk in South
Carolina uh you know he has ties with
Jim kurn who is the sort of political
Godfather of South Carolina um so that
was always very going to be a very tough
uh political environment for us but you
know Michigan is a totally different
story and uh I think we're going to
really surprise folks there but we need
your help yes let's go de24
do it again in 24 and and to you Andrew
you you you did put math back on the map
so we all appreciate you for that yes
it's fixed everything thank you Jeff
take
[Music]
care